for me there are few things more
satisfying than the exclamation point
the finality of a moment that's being
built up in the anime world like the one
instant the one snappy moment which
serves as the big punctuation mark to
something that you've been looking
forward to it often manifests in
physical ways and what better method to
do it than with a good old punch and
that's why we're here today today we're
going over what i think are the most
satisfying the most earned punches we've
seen in the anime sphere so without
further ado here are some of the punches
in anime that were heard all around the
world
starting off the list is thorma punching
out accelerator i've been a huge fan of
the a certain franchise sure the
non-railgun titles have seen better days
now that we're looking at it in
retrospect but there are some moments
from the original series that will
always stay with me one such moment the
punch that resounded in universe and
ended accelerator's mad quest for
transcendence the sisters arc is my
favorite arc for most of the index and
there's few things more satisfying than
seeing this underdog battle end in such
a badass punch it's thormar's signature
move and it shook the world when that
punch connected it's a completely
fitting end to accelerator's quest for
power to be beaten by someone who's
statistically among the weakest people
in academy city weakest beats the
strongest in a surprisingly simple
method and it just drives the point of
the arc and the futility of accelerators
quest for power home
at number nine is lyon punching honest
honest as a character doesn't really
have any redeeming qualities does he i
don't know you tell me there's next to
nothing to like about this character and
while in a sense it makes him perfect
for the antagonistic role he's in it
also makes the scene of leon pummeling
him so satisfying this moment as a whole
is really tense whereas the fights in
the series can be as suspenseful and
thrilling i also feel solemn sadness as
the whole thing unfolded sad because at
that point i knew we'd have seen the
last of leon when she got shot after all
this is a show that kills characters off
without a second thought and were about
to be given another pointless death at
least she had this glorious moment
before passing away i mean still that
doesn't take away from the fact that
this was one of the deaths that
personally hurt me when i saw it happen
she had a better fate in the manga
frankly speaking
you know in one punch man there's
honestly a lack of suspense in terms of
actual fight results i mean that is the
point of the show after all isn't it
with one punch scythe armor dispatches
any villain foolish enough to stand in
his way however this particular moment
was made extra special thanks to a good
friend here moomin rider the little hero
that could we've just seen deep sea king
raising hell for ages on end at this
point and moomin riders brave stan
completely endeared audiences to the
character that's when he's finally sent
flying only to be saved by saitama you
can truly feel the relief and the
redemption of the big hero's survival
it's the ultimate dsx machina and the
moment before it truly softened us for
saitama's arrival and subsequent one
punch to get us elated in triumph of
course the fight ends in a classic side
armor no sell-on one punch finish but
man this is probably the moment we badly
wanted saitama to save the day the most
[Applause]
had a strong debut and i thought that
he'd be a troublesome villain he was one
of the most hated people at the start
for a reason but he ended up getting
knocked out arc after ark with this one
moment happening after the lustre had
worn off still it doesn't make it any
less satisfying to see the scumbag get
punched out by the protagonist nobody
tried his luck far too many times a lot
of people agree that gintoki's punch is
indeed the most deserved one in the
series the build up to it is pretty damn
cool too not quite as chilling as some
of the entries to come but still an
awesome moment to talk about on a more
positive side nobunobu as a character
has quite the nice character progression
he's a character who truly changes
through experience still it doesn't make
this punch any less exhilarating when it
happened
now i'm sure you want to watch all these
anime but you see legal streaming
services can be a pain you'll
undoubtedly find your subscriptions
lacking at one point or another
thankfully our sponsors and friend of
the channel expressvpn is there for me
and i'm able to follow my favorite shows
unhindered and guilt-free using
expressvpn you can unlock the potential
of your streaming services and watch the
full version of these satisfying punches
and more i've used it to watch anime
like hunter hunter and jeebly movies and
now even use it to watch my hero
academia on netflix all you have to do
is open up expressvpn and click on the
indian server and boom your netflix just
went plus ultra your data and online
privacy is also safe and this is
especially important in countries with
more stringent rules on online
activities to find out how you can get
three months free of this amazing
service make sure to click on the link
in the description box or go to
expressvpn.comtube i only want the best
for you awesome viewers so i only
support the best vpn service that we can
all enjoy hope you check this out now
let's get back to the show
natsu punching acnellogia makes it to
the list if there's one thing i love
about fairy tale it's how they make
their finishing blows feel very
impactful and empowering i know it's a
meme at this point but i honestly think
it's made possible because of the whole
nagama power thing there's just a
different kind of passion and energy
seeing these punches and finishing blows
after the heroes channel the source of
their resolves everything comes to a
head with natsu's finisher on aknologia
with everyone cheering him on and the
best rendition of the fairy tale theme
blaring natsu delivers a rainbow colored
punch to end the terror of aknologia
once and for all fairytale fans may have
had differing opinions on the final arc
as a whole but the finisher itself when
viewed in anime form provides one hell
of an emotional gratification i also
like how acne logi's defeat didn't just
come as a result of an aspartame it was
igneous previous sacrifice that rendered
him unable to defend himself and i like
how it didn't weigh such an emotional
moment an arc or two before
memes aside it was such a joy watching
this unfold if you need any proof of the
craziness of the jojo franchise perhaps
i can introduce you to this seven page
sequence of giorno beating up
chickaletta with gold experience in
seven straight pages at first glance the
hero spending seven whole pages beating
up a minor video may not seem like much
but in anime form you get to see 30
whole seconds of glorious pummeling
perfectly adapted and improved from
source material yes it really is a whole
30 seconds and at some point you just
feel sorry for chickalanta or maybe not
he's a jerk who deserves nothing but
overkill for all the deeds he's done
regardless it's a perfectly adapted
scene from a manga reader's perspective
and i just can't help but fanboy over
the attention to detail such as the
number of times giano actually said muda
in the manga
[Music]
versus hawk is an amazing fight to watch
from the build-up of hawke to seeing his
path to becoming the undefeated champion
at that point we all thought that
takamura found his match in this highly
anticipated championship bout and in
eight rounds of intense high stake
action the fight didn't disappoint it
has no shortage of drama that we've come
to love when two fighters give it their
all when that final blow struck and
finally brought hawke down for the count
it was a moment of joy a moment of
triumph hawk hadn't endeared himself to
much of the fans for his ideals and
arrogant attitude and that was a punch
of judgment that sent shockwaves all
over the world for takamura it's just
one of his many glorious moments but for
us viewers it's a punch that changed
everything
talk about a very satisfying end to
what's long being the ultimate face-off
in my hero academia after seasons of
hype and anticipation we finally get the
much-awaited all might versus all for
one fight and it all comes to a head
with this extremely hyped arc it's a fun
thing to look back at too back when this
was airing i never expected the two to
face off this early it's not even
halfway through the series run and
they're already at the last boss all
that got thrown out the window as i was
caught in the excitement of this battle
the two behemoths wage war in a battle
to decide the fate of the world and it
ended in possibly the most exciting way
it could with all might put in his
everything in one last finishing move
that looks and feels more awesome than
anything i've seen before united states
of smash is more than just a finisher it
punctuates the first part of my hero
academia and has left a legacy as the
moment where the status quo shifted and
opened the curtains to a new world
[Music]
hunter hunter fans everywhere have this
as one of the best moments the show has
to offer and is it not the atmosphere in
the execution has been so perfect adult
gone was already a sight to behold but
seeing this pinnacle of our protagonist
full power in action with a resounding
exclamation point made the way very
worth it we don't see gon snap often so
make sure to treasure this moment i get
goosebumps every time i watch this and
it shows a ruthless side to gone that
we'll never likely see again this is one
of the scenes i've looked forward to
when checking out the modern adaptation
of the series and it didn't disappoint
one bit gone's a ruthless edge along
with the animation the black and white
effect all of those come together for an
awesome punch that will be remembered
for years to come
um
[Applause]
we finish up with luffy punching out the
celestial dragon i know it's well
documented that i've been a massive fan
of one piece but just look at it it's
these moments that make me love one
piece so much for a shonen show it's got
a lot of strong themes that resonate
with us today like discrimination and
these things get resolved in some of the
most satisfying ways possible luffy
punching out the celestial dragon
therefore is for me the most satisfying
anime punch because of the context the
build up and how much it establishes the
characters with luffy benefiting from it
the most you gotta love the slow walk
and the whole everyone's eyes on you
atmosphere you know something's brewing
inside luffy and everyone held their
breath for what's to come then bam the
jerk got what he deserved and all hell
breaks loose did anyone actually feel
any pity for the celestial dragon i mean
i didn't i don't think a lot of people
shed a tear when he got his face punched
out with righteous indignation it's a
truly satisfying punch and a gratifying
punishment to someone who showed no
redeeming qualities at all
[Music]
[Music]
and that more or less wraps it up i want
to know if you have any other satisfying
punches that you want to introduce to me
if you do the comment section is open
and i'll gladly take a look at some of
those that you suggested by the way if
you enjoyed this video please don't
hesitate to share the channel with your
friends we've got lots of countdown
videos that you might like there's also
a patreon that you can drop by and check
out if you're up to supporting the
channel you can also hop on the
videotube instagram for some news
related to anime and the channel don't
forget to check out our sponsors of this
video
expressvpn all you have to do is click
the link in the description box or go to
expressvpn.com
vinnie tube for a three month free trial
hope you had a good time i'll be seeing
you in the next video and until then
stay awesome
[Music]
you